a quien le corresponde la
responsabilidad de contrarrestar la
repartición tan inequitativa de la
riqueza y de los recursos en el mundo
sigue siendo una gran contradicción que
pocos acumulen los fondos que sacarían a
millones de la situación de pobreza
buenos días muchas gracias
bueno principalmente al gobierno oa los
gobiernos
en particular en latinoamérica lo que no
es una inercia de muchos muchos años de
altos niveles de pobreza y de esfuerzos
marginales en las últimas dos décadas
hubo caídas en pobreza en toda
latinoamérica pero me digamos no caídas
radicales y con la pandemia
casi todas las ganancias que se han
obtenido en esos 20 años se perdieron
perdón
le quería decir que vamos a hablar un
poco más adelante de la pandemia pero
antes quisiera preguntarle por algo que
nos sucede hace siglos y es a las
transversalidades de los más afectados
las mujeres las minorías los niños las
poblaciones indígenas hay desigualdad
dentro de la desigualdad como podría una
política feminista e inclusiva hacer la
diferencia en los indicadores mundiales
de pobreza
bueno hay medidas de política que pueden
tener efectos importantes
digamos uno de los por ejemplo en género
uno de los grandes problemas es una una
brecha de género en el mercado laboral
tanto en niveles salariales como el
nivel de desempleo y eso tiene que ver
con una cantidad de problemas
por ejemplo la forma en que enfrentamos
los permisos de maternidad
digamos que la forma tradicional hace
que para el empleador la existencia de
permisos de maternidad
sea un costo
asimétrico digamos un costo que afecta
más la contratación de mujeres
entonces esos esfuerzos para que haya
permisos compartidos para terminar y
maternidad pueden ayudar en esta
dirección pero evidentemente hay un
problema cultural de fondo y eso
pues
llevaría décadas y décadas
en apagarse digamos en resolverse
bueno ahora sí qué tan fuerte fue el
golpe de la pandemia cuántos años
perdimos en la lucha contra el
empobrecimiento y a nivel regional donde
estamos peor
y bueno
empieza con la segunda pregunta en estos
países donde la informalidad es más
grande el efecto nocivo de la pandemia
fue peor y las razones y la el trabajo
informal suelen hacerse en las calles de
manera que por un lado los informales no
estaban protegidos por mecanismos
tradicionales de intervención estatal
y por otro lado para el informal estar
en la casa
pues implicaba pobreza inmediata de
verdad que
el efecto sobre ingresos fue mayor pero
además la probabilidad de contagio
también fue mayor entonces esa
interacción entre pandemia y
informalidad generó una asimetría
adicional que fue la asimetría en salud
cuánto se perdió bueno depende del país
pero estamos hablando como de 20 años
más o menos 20 años de avances en
pobreza se perdieron dicho esto parte de
sus avances se han recuperado en el
último año en el caso de colombia que es
donde tengo las cifras más claras que se
hayan perdido más sobre los 6 millones
de empleo de empleos y hoy en la
recuperación la pérdida neta va haciendo
como 600.000 entonces la recuperación
también ha venido con recuperación de
empleos el problema fundamental es que
los efectos de la pobreza así sea
durante un año son permanentes y los las
familias los niños que padecieron
pobreza extrema durante este año
solamente van a tener menos rendimiento
escolar
ht adiós